question
oral questions the honorable leader of
the opposition
last night mps came together to express
their support for ukraine and their
disgust for putin and what he's doing
one of the things that we ask the
government to do to reflect that is to
expel the russian ambassador the deputy
prime minister yesterday said silence is
complicity and following orders is not
an excuse and we would agree with that
in light of the silence from the russian
ambassador will the government expel the
russian ambassador and recall our
ambassador back to canada
[Applause]
russia's egregious and unprovoked attack
on ukraine is a direct challenge to
democracy it's why the minister of
foreign affairs summoned the russian
ambassador to express extreme concern
and disagreement with russia's actions
canada will continue to use all tools at
its disposal to make sure that these
illegal acts are not left unpunished the
people of ukraine have the right to
their sovereignty and territorial
integrity and the right to live free
without fear
the leader of the opposition we expect
the government to take serious action
and expel that ambassador mr speaker
speaker thousands of ukrainians have
fled their country and they are
searching for safety ukrainians don't
want to be permanent refugees they want
to return to their home a sovereign and
democratic ukraine but they need
protection now
canada has always been a welcoming place
for those displaced by war will the
prime minister commit today to allow
allowing visa-free travel for ukrainians
who are wanting to come to canada and
find a safe haven
the right honorable prime
minister is steadfast in the support for
the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine we have been
priority processing applications from
ukraine and bolstering operational
capacity in the region which has allowed
us to approve more applications from
ukrainian nationals in addition to
establishing a dedicated service channel
for ukraine inquiries regarding uk
ukraine are prioritized and we're
continuing to work on more measures as
the situation unfolds uh that will
ensure uh that ukrainians uh can flee to
safety
the leader of the opposition well it's a
little hard getting a direct answer from
the prime minister today let's uh let's
try another question safety security
sovereignty those must be all top
priorities for any government and it
should be canada's priority especially
now
the longer canadian oil gas and lng stay
in the ground the bigger putin's wallet
gets and the more countries like ukraine
and others will continue to be hurt and
threatened by russian aggression
more than ever the world needs canadian
energy
so i'm going to ask the prime minister
will he commit today to changing his
political direction and will he begin to
support the extraction and exportation
of canadian oil gas and honorable prime
minister
[Applause]
mr speaker as a government we have been
there for alberta and saskatchewan and
newfoundland the labrador and their
energy sectors uh we actually uh i'm
moving forward with the trans mountain
pipeline expansion which the
conservatives couldn't get approved and
couldn't get built we're going to
continue to work to ensure
that we are supporting workers in the
energy industry even as we ensure that
we're moving forward in ways that reduce
carbon from our atmosphere and create a
better future with good jobs for
everyone canada has a significant role
to play in the world we will continue to
play it with europe and with other
allies as well
global leader of the opposition
when the prime minister invoked the
emergencies act on february 14th
conservatives and others said it clearly
didn't meet the legal threshold legal
tools were already available to move the
trucks from ottawa the prime minister
moved ahead to invoke the act and even
attached confidence to the vote less
than 48 hours after that vote he revoked
it which proved he used the emergencies
act for his own political gain
isn't it true the prime minister used a
legislative sledgehammer on our country
for his own political advantage
the right honorable prime minister
the emergencies act enabled local
authorities to end the illegal blockades
we've heard from the commissioner of the
rcmp police chiefs experts and political
leadership that it was essential to the
police response and that it offered
precision and clarity as they did their
important work but even after all this
has ended conservative mps still can't
pick a lane canadians want to know do
they stand with blockaders or do they
stand with canadian communities
the honorable leader of the opposition
where's the land we'd like the prime
minister to pick from today is march 1st
and as of today saskatchewan manitoba
alberta ontario and nova scotia they've
all lifted their vaccine mandates
why because it's safe to do so and they
care about mental health and their
economies here at the federal level we
have a liberal government that is
dragging their knuckles because they
become so backwards and regressive in
their thinking when it comes to the need
for restrictions when will the liberals
come out of the dark ages and see that
backseat mandates are so yesterday
[Applause]
speaker on this side of the house we
ground our decisions in science uh we
continue uh to believe uh that keeping
canadians safe is extremely important
but i will highlight that canada
has made significant movements uh on
restrictions of the borders to enable
for more canadians to travel
safely and less onerously when they come
home we will continue to look carefully
at what more measures we can lift or
move forward on to ensure that canadians
continue
to be safe while getting back to the
things we love canadians expect their
governments to keep them safe that's
exactly what we're doing
[Music]
russian tyrants pride appears to have
been wounded
and now he is
viciously and
launching
savagely
extreme attack
attack on an innocent population
canada has placed sanctions on russia
very severe sanctions and that's great
shouldn't the sanctions be kept in place
until the very last russian soldier
leaves ukrainian soil the honorable
prime minister i'd like to thank my
colleague for his question and his
position we fully agree this situation
is not just a matter of
ukraine's territorial integrity it's a
question of the rule of law and the
principles of the united nations and its
charter we should be there to support
those principles and we will keep the
sanctions in place
right up until
russia
recognizes and admits they made a huge
mistake and withdrawal withdraws its
soldiers from ukrainian soil the
honourable member for berlin
i appreciate that mr speaker
another issue
does the prime minister agreed
as an opportunity to promote oil exports
from western canada the right honourable
prime minister
mr speaker in canada
we import
negligible amounts of russian
oil and gas and that was blocked with
the sanctions we imposed a few days ago
but the fact is that europe still relies
very heavily on russian oil and gas and
we
as a world
have to try to offer alternatives
to europe
alternatives to russia
for europe
and we know that the global economy has
to decarbonize but we haven't quite got
there yet
but we will provide the resources
necessary to help our european friends
you know a member for burnaby south
liz
ukrainians are facing a disastrous
crisis
canada must stand up
to president putin
and his unjust and unprovoked war
the united kingdom has
slapped sanctions on belarus
for its role in this war
is the prime minister also prepared
to place sanctions
on belarus
we did that a few days ago but we also
added
sanctions
against belarus
because we know that they've been
complicit and even partners in the
invasion of ukraine
so we had put
sanctions on the government of
belarus and the oligarchs who have
benefited from this situation we
have done that and we will always look
for ways of doing more to punish belarus
for its complicity now i'm a member for
burnaby south we are witnessing a
humanitarian crisis unfold in ukraine
and canada has to do everything we can
in our power to support people in need
one of the things we can do is to
support ukrainians who are seeking
refuge in canada
so will the prime minister commit to a
simple straightforward barrier-free
process for ukrainians who are seeking
solace in refuge in canada
right honorable prime minister mr
speaker over the past number of weeks
seeing the
terrifying possibility of what has come
to pass um we actually been
been preparing uh with immigration uh
canada and our consular resources to
ensure that there are capacities to
treat ukrainian demands recruiting
requests uh much more quickly we are
processing a higher number of uh visas
and
permits and we're looking at uh creating
new programs to further fast-track
applications of people who are fleeing
from this terrible conflict canada will
always stand with ukrainians
and the same question was asked of the
finance minister who said everything was
on the table but what is really on the
table for six days ukraine was under
invasion for six days putin's regime
violated international law and for six
days the russian ambassador was silently
complicit
in war crimes will the prime minister
expel the russian ambassador and recall
our ambassador immediately yes or no the
right honorable prime minister thank you
mr speaker
russia's egregious and unprovoked attack
on ukraine is a direct challenge to all
of us to the international rules based
order to democracy and to people who
care about human rights and social
justice everywhere and that's why our
foreign minister summoned the ambassador
from russia to hear her opinion
immediately and directly and canada will
continue to have that dialogue but will
also remind russia every day of the
responsibilities of their absolute need
to stand up and to be counted and they
will be punished
mr speaker
i asked the prime minister no answer
i asked the finance minister no answer
now the parliamentary secretary has been
sent to tell us that the ambassador was
summoned to be wrapped over the
knuckles all they've done for six days
the ambassador has been complicit
with putin's regime
in these war crimes
when is the government going to expel
the russian ambassador and recall the
canadian one from moscow
[Music]
thank you mr speaker
russia's actions mr putin's actions will
not go unpunished and when we talk about
what we've done let's talk about the
sanctions let's talk about the military
aid let's talk about humanitarian
assistance let's talk about standing
with the people of ukraine and doing
absolutely everything in our power to
make sure that russia is punished and
russia withdraws immediately and we have
a ceasefire and we have peace
remember for calgary forest lawn the
situation for ukrainians is dire mr
speaker many canadians of ukrainian
heritage are worried about their family
members trying to flee the war one
person called the ukraine hotline to ask
about his parents pr application he was
told that someone from ukraine who
applied a year or two ago
had no priority instead of having those
in need get stuck in this liberal-made
immigration backlog will the minister
commit to visa-free travel for our
ukrainian brothers and sisters trying to
flee war
[Applause]
[Music]
in ukraine is uh characterized by
unspeakable violence and we condemn the
harshest terms this war of choice by
president putin that's why we started
preparing more than a month ago by
boosting our operational capacity in the
region it's why we extended a dedicated
service channel to provide reliable
information it's why we created a new
pathway for people who are already in
canada to make it easier to stay and
work and it's why in the very near
future we will have new measures to
welcome more ukrainians who are seeking
safety as they flee this war canada will
be there for ukraine in its time of need
they deserve nothing less
member for calgary forest lawn at the
citizenship and immigration committee
today we agreed to pass a motion in
support of ukraine including calling for
a visa free travel
the liberals voted against it all
opposition parties are calling on the
government to implement visa-free travel
for ukrainians despite the security
processes already in place for people
arriving without visas and at customs
and considering our national security
system why is the liberal government
against visa
visa free travel for our ukrainian
brothers and sisters fleeing war
the honorable minister
[Applause]
mr speaker i can assure the honourable
member that all members of this house
and all parties want nothing more than
to support ukraine in its time of need
that's why we've introduced new measures
to expedite application processing that
have seen 4 000 applications across our
lines of business already approved it's
why we've introduced new measures to
make it easier to stay my interest and
i'm sure the honorable member shares
this perspective is to create a program
that will get the greatest number of
ukrainians to canada as quickly and
safely as possible in the very new near
future i'll have more to say with a plan
that will achieve those ends
member for selkirk interlake eastman
mr speaker i want to thank the
government for sending anti-tank weapons
to ukraine which the conservatives have
been calling for since 2018. i know that
ukraine will make good use of the 100
carl gustav anti-armor weapons that we
are delivering now
non-nato partners like sweden have also
stepped up are sending 5 000
anti-tank weapons to ukraine
additionally ukraine needs more medical
supplies that canada currently has in
storage
will the minister of defense
send ukraine additional weapons improve
first aid kits and roll three hospitals
that canada has
the honorable minister of national
defense
mr speaker i thank my honorable
colleague for that question let me just
be clear that all options continue to be
on the table in terms of our support but
we should recognize that we have sent
support 10 million dollars of lethal and
non-lethal aid 25 million dollars of
non-lethal aid and then just yesterday
as the member rightly pointed out more
anti-tank weapons as well as ammunition
for those
missiles thank you so much mr speaker
oh yeah member for
mr speaker in 2014 when russia attacked
ukraine
stephen harper signaled that canada must
be prepared to respond to potential
russian incursions yesterday the defense
minister told us she would work with our
u.s partners to ensure norad was
modernized in other words the liberals
have done nothing since 2015. this
morning we learn in the media that
russia is massing troops and equipment
for battle in the arctic canada's
sovereignty is at stake when will the
minister tell canadians about her plan
to modernize our northern warning system
the honourable minister of national
defense
mr speaker i appreciate the question
canada will continue to work
with its american counterparts
and that is why
we
have committed
2.5 million dollars by the end of budget
2021 for
our efforts we will continue
talking with our partners in the u.s
and we are going to continue protecting
our arctic sovereignty
members conservatives are using the war
in ukraine to sell dirty oil and gas
their solution is to run pipelines
through quebec to export more fossil
fuels to europe but the u.n secretary
gene secretary general does not agree
he said that as current events reveal
our reliance on fossil fuels makes the
global economy and energy security
vulnerable to geopolitical crises
it's time to accelerate the energy
transition
so mr speaker
does the government
also agree that reliance on fossil fuels
is destabilizing the world
the honorable
thank you mr speaker and i'd like to
thank my colleagues for her question and
for all her work
on
environmental issues and climate change
in the recent in in years past
we agree
that we need to reduce our reliance on
fossil fuels
both for environmental and climate
reasons and to create the jobs we will
need tomorrow and beyond and also to
reduce our reliance on countries like
russia thank you very much the
honourable member for ponzini
the u.n secretary general again
commenting on the
ipcc's terrifying report he called it an
atlas of human suffering because it maps
the areas of the world where people will
suffer the consequences of climate
change half of the world's population is
at risk mr speaker that's a lot of
people which brings us back to the
choice the minister of the environment
will have to make on friday
he has to decide whether or not to
approve the baidu noir
oil project which aims to extract
extract 300 million dollars will he say
no to bay dunord
the honorable minister
thank you mr speaker and once again i'd
like to thank my colleagues
the environmental assessment agency has
done an assessment of the baidu nord
project our government is studying it
and we will uh
give our decision in due course thank
you very much now remember
mr speaker the un's secretary general
said a lot of things
and one of the things he said yesterday
was that the major polluters are guilty
of setting fire to our only home and he
said that the abdication of leadership
was criminal
leadership mr speaker we expect some
leadership from this minister
he himself set the bar very high
for his own performance so i repeat my
question it's very simple will he
approve the baidu norad oil project yes
or no
the honourable minister
thank you mr speaker
my honorable colleague is talking about
leadership
we are the government that has done the
most
in recent years to fight climate change
a hundred billion dollars of investment
mr speaker
over 100 measures to fight climate
change
we went all the way to the supreme court
to defend the carbon tax which our
government brought in so the
leadership's on this side of the house
mr speaker when it comes to climate
change thank you member for sturgeon
river parkland mr speaker back in 2015
the liberals ran on a platform of
transparency that quote the government
and its information should be open by
default that they would quote restore
trust in democracy parliament is setting
up a committee to review their use of
the emergencies act and it is critically
important that the official opposition
have the power to hold this government
to account instead this liberal
government is being obstructionist and
undermining our ability to do our duty
to canadians my question why is this
government so afraid of
[Applause]
accountability i'm confused the party
opposite has three members of their
caucus
and they're cheering that uh they're
very happy that they have the same
number as the government has the
opposition unfortunately decided to
cheerlead the illegal activities that
were happening outside it would be
entirely inappropriate for those that
were cheerleading the type of activities
that we saw the illegal blockades the
illegal occupation to be chairing what
we said instead is that two opposition
parties will chair the process one who
is against the act one who is for the
act that's being reasonable that's being
fair
the honorable member for memishi grand
lake
mr speaker the prime minister called
canadians he disagrees with these people
with unacceptable views racists bigots
misogynists terrorists people that take
up space
yesterday the public safety minister
even said protesters were rapists
experts say there was no such security
threat or financial threat to canadians
given the prime minister voted for it
then revoked it in 36 hours will the
liberals finally admit imposing the
emergency act was wrong
the honorable
government house leader
mr speaker as events unfold in the world
that are deeply serious in the ukraine
as we have finally been able to put the
illegal blockades and the occupation
behind us
i would hope that the the members
opposite would look at the efficacy of
the emergency act how successful it was
in restoring peace and order and that
their questions might be on things that
right now are pressing in the world
i just want to clarify that when you're
asking your question or answering the
question you can shout as long as you
want when you're not singled out and
allowed to i prefer you not shout at
each other
the honorable member
member for paul
mr speaker
this is the story of yet another
demonstration gone wrong because of the
inaction of the prime minister who did
nothing for three weeks
it was disappointing
and then suddenly on february 14 the
prime minister invoked the emergencies
act
three days of debate
monday march 21st the house endorsed the
use of this law thanks to the liberals
on the ndp wednesday march 23rd this
prime minister contradicted himself by
saying the opposite of what he just said
days earlier and revoked the act
the prime minister tell us what happened
between monday and wednesday for him to
flip-flop like that the honourable
minister of public safety
my colleague for his question
since the beginning of the demonstration
but that was our last resort and that
was
following the advice
after that we revoked
the continue
but a lot of product
progress was made and we will continue
to provide resources
mr speaker
there was no longer anything in the
streets of ottawa the streets were clear
the border crossings at kutz emerson and
windsor were cleared without using the
emergencies act and here in ottawa
the prime minister waited three weeks
and then decided one morning to do
to to invoke the emergencies act
and then on monday
it was too late again when the streets
of ottawa were already clear the ndp and
the liberals voted in favor of this act
and then a flip-flop two days later the
prime minister revoked the act
this is a simple question what happened
[Applause]
mr speaker the emergencies act was
essential to allow
police
to put an end to the illegal blockades
and demonstrations all across the
country we've already uh we always said
that we would
not keep it in effect a minute longer
than what's absolutely necessary and
that's what we did we kept our word we
followed the advice of police and we
gave them the tools they needed for
south okanagan west kootenay
mr speaker the ipcc report released
yesterday has a stark warning either we
take action now on mitigation and
adaptation for climate change or risk
suffering even more severe consequences
from extreme weather events wildfires
and floods
but this government continues to give
the fossil fuel industry billions of
dollars in subsidies
so instead of bankrolling the
multinational oil and gas companies why
don't the liberals fund the
infrastructure our communities need to
help prevent catastrophe
the honorable minister of the
environment thank you mr speaker and i
thank my honorable colleague for for his
question um the ipcc report shows what
people
around the world have known for a long
time that countries need to take bold
action to fight climate change mr
speaker and we continue to cut emissions
30 million tons since we've come into
power mr speaker that's almost half of
quebec's entire emissions that we've
managed to reduce because of the
hundreds of measures we've put in place
mr speaker because 100 billion dollars
of investment but we recognize as the
member opposite do we need to do more
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker the winner of opportunity for
a sustainable future for children
grandchildren is closing according to
the new ipcc report a chilling report
according to experts the climate crisis
has already be had irreversible effects
global warming is happening too fast and
this global government is just paying
lip service
in addition to buying a pipeline the
liberals continue to subsidize the
biggest polluters in the oil and gas
industry
the worst in the g20 one of the prime
minister and fossil fuel subsidies to
protect people now and generations to
come
thank you mr speaker i'd like to thank
my colleague for his question the ipcc
report
shows what we all know all countries
need to
make extra
measures to adapt for climate change we
have to continue to reduce emissions and
strengthen our resilience and that is
the reason for which our government has
invested over 2.3 billion dollars mr
speaker in adapting to climate change
and over 100 billion dollars to fight
against greenhouse gas emissions
but we must do even more than this all
of us here encounter and abroad thank
you mr speaker member for kitchener
south hespeler
mr speaker
many canadians are struggling to find
affordable housing including in my
riding of kitchener south hespeler the
need for affordable housing has been
highlighted during the covet 19 pandemic
last week i had the honor of speaking at
a virtual open house for one of our
government's rapid housing initiative
programs in my riding of kitchener south
hespeler can the minister of housing and
diversity and inclusion please tell this
house how our government is building
more affordable housing in kitchener
south hespeler and across canada
the honorable minister for housing hello
mr speaker i want to thank the honorable
member for kitchener south hespeler for
her question but also for her very
strong advocacy on the issue of
affordable housing and recently in the
member's own riding we announced 8.2
million dollars to create 42 new
permanent affordable housing units for
seniors and women at risk of and in fact
experiencing homelessness this is real
action it means 42 canadians now have
the housing that they need and a safe
place to call home this is yet another
example of the national housing strategy
at work in communities from coast to
coast to coast mr speaker thank you
honourable member for calgary midnapore
mr speaker canadians have been plagued
with backlogs throughout this pandemic
everything from immigration applications
to gis payments to parental benefits
yesterday the president of the treasury
board said in the house that 99
of public servants are vaccinated so i
have a simple question for the minister
how many unvaccinated federal employees
did she have to fire to get to 99
percent
the honorable president of the treasury
board
mr chair mr speaker as i said yesterday
vaccines are the best way to bring this
pandemic to an end
public servant stepped up
99
got their first dose 98.7 percent got
their second dose
public servants are responding to the
need of making sure canadians are safe
and healthy during this pandemic those
that need accommodation are being
treated and we will continue to make
sure that these public servants are
respected thank you very much
the honourable member for cyprus hills
grasslands mr speaker yesterday in qop
the health minister praised the province
of saskatchewan on their coven 19
efforts as of monday all covent 19
restrictions have been lifted in my
province
businesses have been fully open and
smiles can be shared between the people
of saskatchewan once again mr speaker
canada has some of the highest
vaccination rates in the world when will
the health minister follow the lead of
the science-backed provincial health
authority and lift all federal mandates
the honorable minister of health
thank you mr speaker gratefulness is a
word that comes to my mind grateful to
the question for the question obviously
grateful to our relationship with
minister merriman and the entire
government of saskatchewan
who've been there to help as we have
like saskatchewan people to go through
this crisis and grateful to the millions
of people in saskatchewan who have made
the right choice and got vaccinated
[Applause]
[Music]
a constituent in my riding has informed
me of the unfair treatment he continues
to receive the border his son lives
the closest place to his son that
provides testing
[Music]
as we've said along our government will
continue to follow the advice of
scientists and public health experts and
the good news is that yesterday mr
speaker we've eased our border measures
that's great news for travelers great
news for the tourism sector great news
for our aviation sector and great news
for communities who are along the
borders thank you mr speaker
the honourable member for peterborough
kawartha you're here thank you mr
speaker i believe the tourism
association would disagree greatly with
that minister
an er nurse messaged me yesterday
because she's in isolation her er is in
desperate is desperately understaffed
and she's stuck at home with zero
symptoms because she was randomly
selected to do a pcr test at the border
on top of the rapid test canadians need
a plan they need answers provinces
across the country are following the
advice of medical health officers and
dropping mandates when will our prime
minister give canadians a plan and a
timeline on when federal vaccine
mandates will be dropped
the honorable minister of transportation
mr speaker canadians support doing
everything we can at our borders to
protect the health and safety of
canadians but also to protect our
economy
prior to yesterday we were testing all
arrivals from non-us travelers to make
sure that incomers are fully vaccinated
and are not carrying the virus yesterday
we changed these measures mr speaker we
no longer test every traveler because we
based on the advice we received for our
public health experts and now we're
accepting antigen tests for our
travelers that's great news for
travelers mr speaker
[Applause]
mr speaker
we were anxious to read the new bill to
modernize the official
it is giving precedence to its law
so that the application of the charter
of french language to businesses under
federal jurisdiction is optional
on a voluntary basis
[Applause]
mr speaker like
the modernization strengthening of the
ola
we recognize the decline of french in
this country and even in quebec
we seem to have a technical problem
we will see
if
sort it out in the meantime i believe
that the minister for heritage
has an answer to the question
mr speaker
the government of canada defending and
promoting
will be in french
an absolute priority for us in this bill
we recognize that we have to do more
we to boost french
in a working language in a service
language we are doing so not only in
quebec but throughout the country and
we'll always be here to defend french
every living former premier of quebec is
asking for it
johnson daniel johnson
and even the very most liberals
is asking for it
even this house
[Music]
under federal jurisdiction in quebec
the honourable minister for canadian
heritage
mr speaker
of canada
intervenes within its fields of
competence and jurisdiction
seeking to strengthen french
for a working language for a service
language not only in quebec mr speaker
but in francophone communities
throughout canada because french
we want to promote french not only in
quebec but everywhere we want more
french want to speak french listen to
french listen to french music and that's
why we're actually mr speaker honorable
member for simcoe north
mr speaker according to angus reid 53 of
canadians can't keep up with the cost of
living and things are going to get worse
the next budget will introduce
significant amounts of new spending and
make inflation worse for canadian
families and on april 1st this
government is increasing the carbon tax
on gasoline by almost nine cents a liter
every day we hear more stories of
canadians telling us they are getting
squeezed mr speaker when will this
government realize it needs to change
its course and cancel its tax and
spending plans
honorable deputy prime minister
[Applause]
the conservatives continue to talk down
the canadian economy with a false
economic narrative so i am glad to have
the chance to share some good news
statscan today released our gdp numbers
for the fourth quarter canada's gdp grew
at an annualized rate of six points
that is the second highest level
in the g7 and it beat market
expectations
the honourable member for saskatoon west
mr speaker i asked the liberals about
inflation in saskatchewan and the
government confirmed the negative impact
of inflation on the poverty line
throughout my province
in fact the poverty rate increased 1.2
percent in saskatchewan and it's only
going to get worse that means an
additional 13 000 people in saskatchewan
are falling into poverty every year
simply because inflation is driving
their costs through the roof mr speaker
why is this government driving
low-income families in saskatoon west
deeper into poverty with their high
spending high inflation policies
prime minister
mr speaker we will take no lessons
it comes to supporting the most
vulnerable people in canada we
introduced the ccb which is indexed to
inflation and which lifted almost 300
000 children out of poverty
we increased the gis also indexed to
inflation and which has helped over 900
000 seniors in fact mr speaker when we
formed government there were 5.1 million
canadians in poverty by 2019 that figure
had dropped to 3.7
the honorable member for flamborough
glenbrook
mr mr speaker the communities of
flambero glambrook have grown
exponentially as young families flee
toronto in search of a more affordable
life
except for now they're feeling the
crunch here too
in january the realtors association of
hamilton burlington confirmed that the
average house price in the hamilton area
is now over 1 million dollars wow mr
speaker with interest rate hikes on the
horizon
when will we see the long-promised
housing plan to address this crisis
and what hope can this government offer
young canadians that have given up on
the dream of homeownership yeah the
honorable minister for housing
i want to thank the honourable member
for the question and i encourage him to
enable his party to actually vote for
the measures that we've brought in place
to enable affordability the party
opposite voted against the vacancy tax
that we were supposed to move forward on
uh they voted against measures to help
first-time home buyers they voted
against measures to improve more
investments in affordable housing
these are the things that we're doing mr
speaker and we'll continue to not only
continue to invest in affordable housing
for the most vulnerable we'll also
continue to make to put in place
measures to encourage more canadians to
turn from renters into homeowners and i
hope the member opposite and this party
can support us
mr speaker the last two years of this
pandemic have underscored the importance
of investing in domestic manufacturing
of vaccines and ppe
plant-based coconut 19 vaccine the
medical vaccine that was approved by
health canada
on the 24th of february can the minister
for health outline how the government is
supporting the use of this vaccine
[Music]
was
approved it was the first
such vaccine to be approved by health
calendar the first in the world to be
approved on a plant-based technology
workers
and partners
are giving us an extra tool to protect
their health and security
lake country thank you mr speaker thanks
to the liberals all winery cidery
brewery and distillery owners will wake
up on april 1st to an increase of their
excise taxes most who i've talked to
have struggled along due to perpetual
lockdowns and most do not fall within
bill c2's benefits and any potential
offset does not come close to bridging
their losses one winery owner that i
spoke to will have a 50 000 excise tax
hit
unlike the finance minister i've owned
my own small business and i've had to
read financial statements so will the
minister cancel the april fool's day
excise tax increase
[Applause]
mr speaker like other taxes and benefits
the alcohol excise duty rate is
automatically adjusted each year this
approach provides certainty to the
sector while ensuring our tax system is
fair for all canadians and let me tell
you mr speaker if the member opposite
really wanted to support canada's small
businesses the member opposite and her
party should have voted with us
to support the business support measures
that helped canadian small businesses
get through this that's true thank you
that's right member for york simcoe
mr speaker on april 1st the price of
alcohol will go up yet again for
canadians due to the liberals ever
increasing escalator tax grab on beer
wine and spirits canadian restaurants
and bars will continue to struggle due
to the impacts of the pandemic another
tax hike is the last thing they need
this automatic permanent tax increase
must be reviewed by parliament every
year so we can support the places that
serve canadian alcohol
and the farmers and producers who make
it will the liberals put a cork in their
ever increasing excise tax on canadian
alcohol
the honorable deputy prime minister
mr speaker the increase is less than one
fifth of one penny
per can of beer
and there are specific measures that
take into consideration the needs of
craft brewers and wineries
and let me tell the members opposite
something else
they should have paid attention to the
wine growers of canada and beer canada
both organizations called for an end to
the blockades that hurt their business
honourable member for niagara falls
mr speaker tourists from around the
world are now making their travel plans
for the fast approaching summer tourism
season but the federal government's
requirements for pre-departure testing
at canadian borders stands in the way of
making canada an attractive destination
yesterday the canadian travel and
tourism roundtable said the policy is
not grounded in science or evidence they
also called on the government to drop it
for the sake of the economic recovery in
our hardest hit tourism sector can the
federal liberals tell travelers when
they will drop the pre-departure travel
requirements
the honorable minister of health
thank you mr speaker again very grateful
to the question in particular because my
region my city my riding of quebec is a
writing of exceptional quality that
attracts thousands if not millions of
foreigners and tourists over years we're
very proud of that that's why we're so
proud that the measures to which the
measure alludes to have been reduced
have been relaxed just a day ago will
continue to work to support the tourism
industry while protecting the safe the
health and safety of travelers and
workers
the honorable member for scargu agent
court mr speaker at the onset of this
pandemic our government acted swiftly by
introducing emergency measures to keep
canadians financially afloat while these
benefits have been crucial for so many
families including those in my riding of
scarborough agincourt i have personally
heard from seniors that it has resulted
in a reduction of their gis payments
they rely on to make ends meet can the
minister of seniors inform the house on
what we are doing to strengthen income
security for seniors that are dependent
on gis
honorable minister for seniors thank you
mr speaker mr speaker i want to thank
the member from scarborough asian court
for her work and her advocacy for
seniors in her community and in this
house
mr speaker when it comes to supporting
the most vulnerable all government has
always been there and that is especially
true for low-income seniors we have
committed to supporting seniors who
counted on pandemic supports and had
their gis impacted we made a major we're
making a major investment through an
automatic one-time payment for those
affected seniors we unanimously passed
bill c-12 in this house and i'm
confident that the other place will do
the same mr speaker seniors know that
our government will always be there for
them
the honourable member for vancouver east
more than half of canadians say they are
struggling with the cost of living and
yesterday a report from the national
housing council confirmed that the
government is not making housing more
affordable for canadians it also said
that the liberal government's national
housing strategy is only meeting a
fraction of the existing need after six
years of half measures the housing
affordability gap has only increased and
canadians are paying the price for the
government's failures
when will the liberals stand up for
canadians by cracking down on housing
speculators and make the needed
investments to build 500 000 units of
social and co-op housing
honorable minister for housing
mr speaker i want to thank the
honourable member for her question we
thank the housing council for their work
and we commit to examining closely the
recommendations contained in the report
that they've prepared we're the
government that reintroduced federal
leadership in the housing sector we've
brought significant resources through
the national housing strategy which has
grown from 40 to 40 billion dollars to
over 72 billion dollars the honourable
member mentioned the co-op sector with
the government that saved the corpses
the co-op sector after it was abandoned
by the conservatives to the tune of 318
million dollars that will guarantee
subsidies for a long time for the most
vulnerable members of the community mr
speaker excellent the honourable member
for winnipeg center
mr speaker last week a man froze to
death in a downtown winnipeg bus shelter
in minus 30 weather we have a
homelessness crisis in winnipeg center
that is costing precious lives and
people are forced to sleep out in the
cold because the liberals national
housing strategy fails to fix the
housing crisis people need real
solutions mr speaker when will the prime
minister respect the right to housing as
a human right and make adequate
investments to sure
nobody else dies because they can't find
a home they can afford
minister
mr speaker let me make this absolutely
clear even if one canadian finds
themselves on the street it uh it
diminishes us as a society so i share
the grief of the honorable member but i
want to reiterate our support for
investments in affordable housing i've
lost count on the number of times that
i've been to winnipeg virtually and in
person to make announcements
through rapid housing initiative the
national housing co-investment fund the
affordable housing innovation fund the
the rental construction financing
initiative reaching home uh the canada
manitoba housing benefit the canada
manitoba bilateral agreement on housing
we are doing everything that we can and
we'll continue to do more
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm afraid that's all the time we have
for our questions today
that's all the time we have the
honourable member for saanich gulf
islands thank you mr speaker it's it's
difficult when there's so much noise in
this place you probably
didn't know how bad it was and i know we
can't rise and question period on a
point of order but i had to turn my
microphone up as high as i could to hear
the honourable member from rapontony
from the enormous roar of heckling
against her as she spoke that violates
our standing orders it violates standing
order 16 and finally standing under 18
and mr speaker i know i know you're
doing your very best to remind people to
keep order
but it becomes hard when members can't
hear other members pose questions
because of of the rudeness and the noise
i want to thank the honorable member for
her intervention and i want to remind
all the members that when someone else
is speaking as as right now please
respect
please respect each other and try to
follow the rules of the house because
that's how good debate takes place
the honorable member for
oakville north burlington is rising on a
point of order thank you mr speaker
during question
order
order
thank you we're about to have someone
get rise on a point of order so we want
to hear what you're saying the honorable
member for oakville north burlington mr
speaker during question period the
minister the member from miramishi grand
lake claimed that the minister of public
safety called the protesters